Hi everyone. I'm here at a conference
for Somali ex-Muslim
Christians and I knew you two guys, but
there are a lot of Somali ex-Muslim
Christians. So, someone's been doing a
lot of work, but I'm shocked especially
especially lots of young people lots of
young Somali ex-Muslim Christians and
they are excited. They are excited. So,
lots of people have no idea that this is
even going on. So, why don't you tell us
what's been happening?
Yeah, thank you David and thank you for
being here with us in this conference.
It is
a pleasure to us and we thank you for
coming here. So, this conference has
been going for back 18 years. When we
started we started with three people all
in Europe ex-Muslims Somali ex-Muslims
Christians now, but now we can gather
more than thousands, but we we are just
you know, hosting more than 120 Somali
believers you know, ex-Muslims now and
by grace of God yeah, the Lord has
blessed our
our gathering here.
Yeah, Jesus is building his church among
the Somalis and now is the harvest time
and yeah, thank you so much all the
people who prayed for the Somalis
Muslims. They used to say Somalia 100%
Muslim Sunni country, but not anymore.
Praise God more than 100 people are here
120 Somalis. So, they cannot call
themselves 100% Somalia is not 100%
Muslim no more. Even the Sheikhs are
admitting now, isn't it? Thank God yes.
And I just want to say my new favorite
thing in the world my new favorite thing
in the world was
watching watching a speaker talk about
the history of Muhammad and some of the
information in the Muslim sources that
lots of Muslims aren't familiar with and
watching Somali ex-Muslim Christians
laugh at some of the really stupid
things about Muhammad. It is is really
really awesome and then hearing them
sing
praise songs about Jesus. Awesome
awesome time. So, why don't you tell
everyone a little bit about what you
guys been doing over these years. You're
both
Somali ex-Muslim Christians. Yeah, and
when the Lord saved us, you know, he did
not just
let us just relax and sit and he gave us
you know, this ministry or outreach
ministry and we reaching out to our
people. If we don't reach them out who
who else would reach them out because we
feel compassion as Jesus felt compassion
with people. So, we feel a compassion
and we want to we want all of them to be
saved. That's what we are doing now. We
doing the outreach. We doing the
discipleship and we yeah, we doing all
things we we can. So, yeah, by grace of
God the Lord has blessed our ministry
and our outreach and we thanking him for
doing that. Yeah, and by the grace of
God we are saved. Sheena and I we've
been in Europe more than 30 years now,
but 20 years ago when the Lord saved me
we were already here 14 years in the
Sweden and become citizen and have a
kids, but no one shared the gospel with
us. No one will come and and share the
gospel with you. So, because of that the
Lord saved me first and later on my
husband get saved 4 years later, but he
saved me through and I come out from
Islam because I've seen American man
who'd been beheaded in the name of Allah
Allah in Iraq 2004. His name was Nick
Berg rest in peace, but because of that
I came out the Lord himself came to me
in my dream and show me heaven and it's
most beautiful place. And also he showed
me another place very dark place and he
said all your family are there, but but
because you believe in me fear not my
child. So, from that moment I knew Jesus
is the only way to go to heaven and I
know my people are perishing without
knowing the
Christ is the only way to heaven. So,
they when the Lord saved me and sent me
and when the Lord saved my husband he
added and it is amazing now the ministry
is growing. We just reaching out our
people. We just want to share the love
of Christ with everyone because there is
a Somalis who've been in the west 20
years 25 years and never hear the gospel
because people not going to them and
faith comes by hearing hearing the word
of Jesus. So, yeah. Now, you guys
you guys do a lot on social media
posting videos, but you also travel
around a lot and
I've been hearing that you
you when when someone converts you try
to plug them into the local church.
Sometimes there is no local church. So,
how are you navigating the various the
various situations for the people you're
trying to reach? Yeah, and those who
live in western country those who can't
have churches or local churches we
always make connection to the local
church. We have networking, but those
who cannot have that kind of opportunity
like those who live in Somalia or you
know, majority Muslims we are the church
and we teach them. We disciple them and
we have also online
online Sunday church.
>> Sunday service. Sunday service you know,
we have established course online also.
So, that is where we they can grow in
their faith and it's not only outreach
so that it is also teaching and
discipling new believers. So, we want to
make disciple who can disciple others
and leaders who can lead others. Even
you now David you have seen so many
young people and they doing the similar
like what what we have done we were
doing last 20 years or 16 years, but
praise God now they we have a lot of
young people who are on fire for the
Lord and want to share the gospel to the
Somali Muslims even second generation as
well not only first but also second
generation and the third and thank you
so much David you've been an inspiration
for all of us
and because Jesus uh
saved my husband through you. When I
become faith to Christ, he wanted to
take me back to Islam and he will attack
Christianity and I did not know how any
any idea about you guys for Jesus or
Muhammad program and your teachings
and
touch his heart and that's why he left
Islam and now he's follower of Christ.
So, because we are doing this we are
doing together with you because your
teaching is so important for us and
especially even now young generation who
want to reach out to our people in
Facebook YouTube Tik Tok and that's why
we have apologetic this year and that's
why we have you brother yes. Uh
How many baptisms are happening
tomorrow?
Yeah, yes we don't know yet exactly, but
we know for sure yeah, eight people may
maybe baptized this time. And I've seen
lots of pictures with you guys baptizing
lots of people. I did want to ask about
something that was interesting because
first time I've ever heard of it, but
apparently there are there are people
who come to Christ in a country where
there is no church. There are no
Christians around them. You can't get to
them. They can't get to you and so
you've kind of problem solved with what
you say baptisms over Skype? On Skype
Skype baptism or online baptism yeah.
Yeah, Skype yeah.
Yeah, we started that long time ago
because we were
thinking how can we go? We cannot go to
them and they cannot come to us and the
Lord gave us that
in our heart.
Because everyone will be baptized in the
name of the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit. It's not our name and Jesus is
everywhere. So, we said let us teach
them and baptize them on online. So,
Skype baptism on Skype we did it and we
started before the COVID. And I remember
COVID time even our churches started
doing that and some churches in
in the west when we had COVID time UK we
locked down almost 2 years no going to
church or anything, but people in our
church they started baptizing on Skype
and they said Sheena and I Sheena you
were doing this years, but now we also
doing that and and started. It is
amazing. You have seen yeah, David you
know, yeah. Yeah, it's it's amazing
because when I hear when when a a
Christian in like America hears that
it's like
what are you talking about? You have to
you have to be there to be baptizing
someone because
there's no situation where you wouldn't
be there to baptize someone, but it's
just it's a reality of the world that
there are people who are in places where
you can't get to them and that's why I
love love what you guys are doing.
You're seeing problems and then figuring
out figuring out ways figuring out ways
to help people. So, Also I want to add
because of baptism on Skype and when we
started one of the person we
many people we baptized on Skype, but
one of them young man he started
traveling and going
other villages and if we have new
believers he will actually go there and
baptize because he was one of them we
baptized on Skype and he did it that
together with us. We teaching them, but
he will go and baptize. So, praise God.
All right. So, everyone be sure to
follow Sheena and Shanaya on Somali
Christian TV. Ex-Muslims. Ex-Muslims.
That's our English channel the other one
is Somali language. So, Somali Christian
TV ex-Muslim. And I'll have I'll have
all the links to that in the description
box.
Thank you. Thank you for having us
David. God bless you.
Hi everyone. [snorts] Sheena and Shanaya
just headed over to the cafeteria. So, I
wanted to record
a little extra clip here.
Somalia is a pretty terrible place in
terms of persecution of anyone who
converts to Christianity
terrorism
the fighting among various tribes and so
on very very very very bad place.
But it doesn't have to be. Doesn't have
to be.
So, I would encourage you. I would
encourage you to financially support
Sheena and Shanaya. I happen to know
that they are massively underfunded
given the amount of work that they're
doing and the things they're
accomplishing in this world. When they
reach a Somali Muslim with the gospel
and that Muslim becomes
a Christian
very frequently
that person is ostracized by his or her
family and so on. And so
it's up to Christians. It's up to
Christians to step in and help with
that. So
um you got to look around at the world
and see who's doing
the work that really really needs to get
done. And Shania and Shino and those
they work with
are doing some amazing work that needs
to get done. That's why I'm here helping
out with what they're doing and that's
why you should be helping them, too. So
the link is in the description box. I
will check out ways to support them
financially and put the links there.